[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS
WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
POLITICAL PARTIES USUALLY ROOT
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
WHEN ONE PARTY FAILS, THE OTHER
RETURNS TO POWER.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE INVESTED
SO MUCH IN TRUMP'S FAILURE THEY
ARE ROOTING FOR AMERICA TO FAIL.
HERE IS BILL MAHER.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE BOTTOM HAS TO
FALL OUT AND I AM HOPING FOR IT.
ONE WAY YOU GET RID OF TRUMP IS
A RECESSION.
EITHER ROOT FOR A RECESSION OR
LOSE YOUR DEMOCRACY.
JESSE: HE WANTS AMERICANS TO
LOSE THEIR JOBS AND THEIR MONEY
SO TRUMP'S APPROVAL RATING GOES
DOWN.
IT'S EASY FOR MAHER TO ROOT FOR
A FAILING ECONOMY BECAUSE HE'S
RICH AND FAMOUS.
>> HIP HIP MORE RAY,
UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO ME IN MY
LIFE.
JESSE: KEEP TALKING, NANCY, YOU
ARE HURTING THE DEMOCRATS.
THE MEDIA ATTACKED PROGRESS ON
THE PENINSULA.
>> A SUMMIT IS NOT AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR THIS AMERICAN
PRESIDENT IT'S A MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR KIM JONG-UN.
BOTH MEN ARE LIARS.
KIM JONG-UN LIES AND HE SAID
DONALD TRUMP LIES.
>> THIS IS NOT A DATE.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
THIS IS NOT JUST LUNCH.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
JESSE: I THOUGHT THE DEMOCRATS
WERE ALL ABOUT DIALOGUE AND
GIVING PEACE A CHANCE.
THE WORST WAS CHELSEA HANDLER.
PUTIN IS GIVING TRUMP TALKING
POINTS AND ACTIONS TO TAKE TO
UNDERMINE THE VERY COUNTRY HE'S
FROM.
WE HAVE A DOMESTIC ENEMY RUNNING
OUR COUNTRY, PISSING ON ALL
ALLIES, AND SHOWS FEALTY ONLY TO
PUTIN.
THIS IS NOT AMERICA.
THIS IS RUSSIA.
I HOPE KIM JONG-UN EATS DONALD
TRUMP.
WE HAVE THE LEFT CALLING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES A
DOMESTIC ENEMY COMPARING HIM TO
A DICTATOR AND ROOTS AGAINST
PEACE.
JOY BEHAR AT THE VIEW PUTTING
THE CHERRY ON TOP SPEAKING ABOUT
OUR STRICTER SOUTHERN BORDER
POLICY.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD NOT TOLERATE
THIS.
THIS IS LIKE GERMANY.
I MEAN, COME ON, PEOPLE.